hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that ate the devil fruit given
us the power to ruin your favorite
childhood Series so as the general
audience has started to cool on
superheroes the bigwigs over at
Hollywood have been looking for their
next big Treasure Trove of Ip they can
plunder and turn into billion dollar
hits and one of the wells that they've
been turned into in recent years anime
and even though legendary Classics like
Dragon Ball Ghost in the Shell and
Cowboy Bebop haven't turned out that
great hasn't stopped them from trying
some more feels like every week we hear
about a beloved anime getting its own
live-action adaptation uu Hakusho is
getting one at Netflix gundam's getting
the big screen treatment over at Netflix
Netflix is trying their hand at my hero
Academia Sword Art Online is making the
jump over to Netflix wow that is a lot
of Netflix I hope it turns out better
than Death Note
wait they're doing another live-action
Death Note at Netflix okay so that's a
lot and given Netflix's previous track
record I think it's fair to be a bit
nervous but hey who knows maybe they've
figured out a way to course correct the
ship in fact we won't have to wait long
to see if that's the case because a few
days after this Theory airs they're
gonna be dropping their version of a
live action one piece in case you don't
know about this massively popular anime
one piece is all about the swashbuckling
Monkey D Luffy and his ragtag crew of
straw hat Pirates all searching for The
Treasure of the last king of the Pirates
as the king explained before he died my
fortune is yours for the taking but
you'll have to find it first I left
everything I own in one piece now if you
thought this was gonna be a quick
Adventure
oh you sweet summer child you're so
wrong one piece is one of the world's
longest running anime with over a
hundred manga volumes 1 000 episodes in
a quarter Century's worth of content
with no real signs that they're gonna be
stopping anytime soon gotta be real here
with you loyal theorist we've been
wanting to cover one piece on the
channel for a long time there's just so
much that you have to watch and read to
cover your bases watching the anime
alone would take you over 17 days
straight with no sleep and no bathroom
breaks just from that alone I was really
skeptical when Netflix announced that
they were making the show but after
seeing the trailer yeah I've got some
cautious optimism I'm Monkey D loopy and
I'm gonna be king of the Pirates here's
hoping they stick The Landing but with
this Netflix adaptation coming along and
basically asking what if
the one piece is real
I've got some cogs turning in my head
yeah what if the one piece were real and
by that I mean what if the world of One
Piece were real this is a franchise with
an incredibly unique setup in a world
that is instantly recognizable so what
would happen if we applied real world
science to it that's right friends were
doing a certified theorist classic today
if this thing were real it would be
absolutely terrifying because make no
mistake if the world of One Piece were
real it would be dangerous disastrous
and it would ruin basically any attempt
to better your life hoist your Jolly
Rogers loyal theorists were set in sail
so before we can really dive into why
you wouldn't want to live in the world
in one piece we have to break down just
how different it is from our own zooming
out you can immediately spot some pretty
big differences first of all almost the
entire planet is covered in ocean with
some small island continents and
archipelagos dotted here and there on
the real planet Earth with all of our
massive continents about 70 of the
planet's surface is water so for the
world of One Piece we're talking closer
to 90 the biggest landmass is
undoubtedly the red line a very long
very skinny continent of red Rocky
Mountain jutting out out of the ocean
which runs all along what's basically
the prime meridian of the planet because
of this one piece's oceans are split
into five main bodies of water the four
biggest are the north south east and
west Blues basically separated into the
four hemispheres of the planet but the
fifth body of water is actually the most
important the grand line a wide ocean
stream that wraps around the entire
equator of the planet this stretch of
ocean is incredibly perilous and often
called the most dangerous in the world
normal compasses don't work here
currents and weather are erratic and
extreme and much of the wildlife is
deadly there's a reason it's earned
itself the nickname the pirate's
graveyard so other than that forbidding
label on the grand line what would the
big issues of this planet actually be
well the first problem the world of One
Piece would face actually comes from its
most iconic feature the fact that it's
just covered in ocean water see this one
fact would probably mean that the
world's inhabitants don't have time to
fight over who's gonna get the one piece
first because they're too busy fighting
over another more essential Resource One
required to survive water uh fresh water
I'm sure I don't need to tell you ocean
water not safe to drink all that salt is
not gonna give you a good time time in
the real world fresh water only makes up
about 2.5 percent of the planet's total
water supply and amongst that already
minuscule percentage most of that is
trapped in the atmosphere in ice caps or
is so deep under Earth's surface that it
won't see the light of day the only
water that's truly available for humans
to consume are those found in
underground aquifers or in freshwater
lakes and rivers I mean here's a crazy
fact for you if all of Earth's water
were shrunk down to the size of your
typical water bottle the amount that
would be fresh and available would be
about a quarter of a milliliter that is
literally less than a drop in a bucket
now remember all these calculations are
in relation to Earth a planet that has
30 percent of its surface covered in
land land that has massive lakes and
rivers and even we still have fresh
water shortages now take away all the
continents the Great Lakes the rivers
the streams and replace it all with even
more giant oceans full of undrinkable
salt water people are going to struggle
sure some islands in one piece probably
have fresh water obviously Real World
Islands like those in Hawaii have plenty
of fresh groundwater reserves and local
spring water but those can run dry and
pumping wells in their coastlines put
you at a massive risk risk of
accidentally sucking up ocean water
contaminating your pool factor in The
Limited Farmland available on the
islands and you've suddenly created a
world that's going to be forever in
Conflict not over a piece of pirate
treasure but over a lack of food and
water the second major environmental
problem you're going to run into in the
world of one piece is coming from its
second most striking physical feature
the red line continent that basically
cuts the planet in half how so well this
is basically going to make a ton of the
islands on the planet borderline
impossible to live on to explain what I
mean let's just take a look at this map
of our very real world specifically the
west coast of the United States you ever
notice how so much of the West Coast is
incredibly green basically running from
Canada all the way to Central California
everything is covered in trees and
Wildlife it's beautiful and then there's
almost a straight line where everything
to the east becomes much more Brown full
of deserts and dry grasslands why does
it happen well that straight line
separating these two regions is the
Cascade mountain range see there's
basically a permanent Breeze flowing
into North America from the Pacific
Ocean until it reaches the Cascades and
is suddenly deflect acted up that rapid
upward movement forces the moisture
carried by the wind to condensate making
a bunch of rain and creating an
ecosystem that's fit for a bunch of
plant growth this is why cities in the
Pacific Northwest are so famously rainy
and by the forests there are so abundant
but on the opposite side of the mountain
range you have the opposite effect since
all the moisture was taken out of the
air by the mountains the ecosystems are
much drier and hotter on the other side
the phenomenon is fittingly known as the
rain shadow effect since the mountains
are casting a metaphorical shadow where
there's no rain on the far side of the
range so now let's apply what we just
talked about to the world of one piece
since the red line is basically a giant
ring of incredibly tall mountains it's
going to cast an equally enormous rain
shadow since the grandlin ocean current
travels from west to east then we would
expect the wind to also be hitting that
western side of the redline mountain
range making the Eastern side of the red
lines devastatingly dry and wouldn't you
know what that's exactly where our
Intrepid Straw Hat Heroes start their
Adventure the first six arcs of one
piece of story take place in the East
blue ocean and eventually end up at the
red line so if this planet were even
somewhat realistic every single Island
they visit at the beginning of the show
would be an arid desert Wasteland where
there just isn't a lot of water and rain
for life to take hold and hey it gets
even worse from there when you take into
account the next aspect of the world of
One Piece the grand line or rather
what's around the grand line see
flanking above and below the ground line
is a stretch of sea known as the calm
belt and while that might sound like
it's going to be smooth sailing it
actually creates a giant problem the
comb belts here aren't just expanses of
pleasant Seas they're completely still
and I mean completely still in contrast
all the crazy currents and unpredictable
Winds of the ground line the calm belts
have no wind to catch your sails no
currents to carry you along and that
right there would be outright disastrous
maybe even apocalyptic in a real-life
climate system if water and wind just
flat out stopped like it hit a brick
wall at the calm belt that means that
the oceans in the northern and southern
hemispheres aren't sharing any water
similarly since the redline continent is
basically dividing the world in half it
means that the oceans in the west and
Eastern hemispheres are also not sharing
water besides a pathetic trickle that
just gets through at the reverse
Mountain basically each ocean in the
world of one piece is in its own
entirely enclosed system why is that so
bad temperature because the planet's a
big old spheroid the central part of the
Equator receives a whole lot more of the
sun's heat compared to the poles that's
one of the big reasons that places like
Central America Central Africa and
Southeast Asia have such warm tropical
climates however the currents running
throughout our oceans transport the
warmer Waters from the equator down
towards the poles thereby increasing the
overall temperature of those areas and
making them more temperate and habitable
for more creatures including us humans
if you want a really good example of how
this works look no further than Europe
you ever notice how far north Europe
actually is on the map cities known for
their warmer climates like Rome actually
sit on the same latitude as more
notoriously cold climates like Boston
Europe is able to maintain a warmer
climate in part thanks to these ocean
currents so if those currents were to
just somehow stop large parts of Europe
and North America would likely
experience incredibly long periods of
freezing conditions devastating trade
and agriculture in those areas now apply
this to the world of One Piece the
warmer Waters inside the grand line are
essential actually trapped inside the
ground line they can't be distributed to
the northern and southern parts of the
world that would in essence make those
parts of the globe permanent Arctic
wastelands unfit for most habitation let
alone any tropical island Pirate
Adventures now all of this is awful and
if one piece were anything remotely
close to realistic this paints a picture
of a devastating hellscape basically
half the world would be desert a lot of
the northern and southern hemispheres
would be frozen over and there would be
very few resources across the board to
sustain any sort of population the long
and short of it the world of one piece
is totally messed up not only with the
way the world is built result in
something completely unlivable for a
huge percentage of the surface but the
natural phenomenon that we see coming
from the grand line don't only make it
dangerous for sailing it also completely
destroys any possibility of
technological advancement on that planet
things would basically be stuck at the
technological level of the Industrial
Revolution or just before which hey once
you know it that's exactly what we're
seeing in one piece everyone is
basically just sailing ships around
engines of any sort are exceedingly rare
in any sort of Transportation or
technology usually comes from the use of
the weird Wild life on the planet her
magical power is granted by the devil
fruit so in reality when you look at it
for a scientifically inaccurate as this
world is end result is largely what
you're seeing on screen a bunch of
people leaving their resource starved
Island in Hunt of something better hi
diddle DD a pirate's life for me but hey
that's just a theory a film Theory and
cuts